(peaceful music)
- Dubai, for me, is a chance to be a part
of building the foundation for
the underground music scene.
I think all feeling can be felt in music.
I've been diagnosed with
a critical hearing loss,
so I have really two choices,
stop making music and the other option is
making music while my ear supports me.
I choose the latter.
(techno music)
My name is Aaron Kim, aka Tacit.
I do sound design and
make electronic music.
I'm from South Korea and
have been living in Dubai
for nine years now.
I'm, in fact, a cellist,
and I changed my whole
music-making process
with electronic music
because in electronic music
there is no wrong and right.
You don't need to follow any structures.
You are 100% free.
Classical music is very, very strict.
What I love about electronic music
is you don't have any rules, any theories,
nothing to follow.
When I need or want, I
go out and record sound
from the ocean, from the desert,
come back home to my electronic equipment
and I start to make music with the sounds
I recorded earlier.
I'm trying to incorporate my cello sound
in a very unconventional sense.
It's like heavily synthesized,
heavily granulized, chopped up.
I think the very basic
foundations and backbone
of any city is art and music.
There's a lot of people
setting up new things here.
There's a record store called Flip Side
run by my friend Shadi.
He was the first guy to open
a record store in Dubai.
The underground music
scene is really growing
in Dubai, and it's new.
Living and creating in Dubai means
I'm part of growing and
building that scene.
So many people here are like me.
They've set up home here and
are bringing a little bit
of what's theirs into the city,
which in turn, I think, is creating
a really strong creative
undercurrent in Dubai.
(electronic tone chiming)